it's the season debut for john de
plantier recalled this week from reno
john duplantier an elite physical
specimen out there on the mound he has
enormous hands which allows him to get
tremendous spin on his off-speed stuff
tremendous backspin on that four-seam
fastball you saw his numbers there in
reno this year and two starts the switch
hitting second baseman tommy edmond
who's done a nice job in their lead off
spot will lead it off
nine stolen bases on the year and how
about that start for john duplantier 94
and he rings up tommy edmonds welcome
back duke yeah absolutely freezes him
with a fastball right there at 94 down
and in that's usually a hot zone for a
left-handed hitter but edmond could not
pull the trigger here's the other half
of this new cardinals 1-2 punch the
former rocky nolan arenado
that's a fair ball backhanded by escobar
long throw
and they got him in first good start for
john duplantier diamondbacks coming up
carlos martinez to not factor into the
decision in his first start off the
injured list
missed a couple of weeks had a sprained
ankle started friday night against the
cubs
two runs and four hits six innings and
eventually the cardinals dropped that
game 12-3 and there's a look at his
hyundai pitch arsenal pretty much
everything just what is he going to
throw
tonight that is going to be successful
you could tell marta a switch hitter
there's the breaking pitch and a strike
in the first strikeout for carlos
martinez he went with the off-speed
pitch and cattell gave up on it well
yeah he gave him the signal for the
change up and he shook it he wanted to
throw the slider and that's a
you know that's a sharp a slider for a
strike that we've seen from carlos and a
three-two count with two down
lined into the shift and the glove of
tommy edmond one two three go the
diamondbacks country out of here molino
leading off
a swing and a line driving to center the
answer is yes it's a base hit played on
the third bounce by cattell martay and
yachty smoked that one right back
through the middle there's tyler o'neil
so with 30 games he's got 18 driven in
and eight home runs
o'neill left center
adios
welcome back tyler two-run bomb
holy smokes two-nothing cardinals this
is a homer this ball this ball hits the
scoreboard danny oh yeah
high up on the board wow
that was way up there goldschmidt 3-0
pitch back-to-back walks and he walks in
a run nick ahmed batting 215. here it
comes swang and amaze struck him out he
struck out three of the last four and
four overall and that's seven up seven
down to start his night nasty weapon to
have right there that change up
right-hander on right-hander is not
normal steven fogg another full count
delivery swing and a miss
strikeout number five and two in the
inning that is why it is
the worst to be an eight-hole hitter
right there all smiles on the mound
let's celebrate he's feeling it i mean i
realize it's the pitcher at the plate
but you can just see how he's receiving
the ball back the way he's hopping off
the mound the one-two pitch strikes out
the side here in the third how about
that carlos martinez first time through
the lineup six
strikeouts pitch number eight of the
at-bat right here 3-2
goldschmidt lines it into right that
ball is down
and goldie will make the turn around
first he's thinking two on his way to
second and in there with a double
on base for the second time it's a good
piece of hitting right here sinkers he
keeps fighting him off that's just a
really nice job trying not to do too
much nolan aronado 2-1
2-1 ripped and fair into the corner off
the bat of arenado
goldschmidt will score and it's
four-nothing st louis
back-to-back doubles for the cardinals
i'm sure they've seen this before in uh
arizona
aronato hitting a double and down the
line there but not back to back with
their old guy that used to be at first
we talked about it now arenado has
destroyed
the diamondbacks all his games against
them
in the national league west and he's
made it four nothing rojas their lead
off hitter who is walked and also
grounded out lined to nolan arenado and
that turns into two everything going
right right now for carlos martinez six
no hate innings for carlos martinez can
tell so
breaks up the no-hitter hell muscles up
a lead off single l is at third escobar
is it first with nobody out well here's
a bet they need to get going david
peralta has been a little quiet lately
david sends the 2-0 out to left o'neal
won't get there that's off the wall here
comes escobar martay is home eduardo
coming in the freight trains got a
two-run double i think they're gonna say
fan interference here
reached over and grabbed it that cost a
run that cost us a run carlos martinez
had a no hitter through six runs into
three consecutive base hits to open up
the seventh so mike schultz will go to
his bullpen for the left-hander
hennesses cabrera second and third
nobody out the 01 pitch to smith
haven knocks it into the gap that'll get
two runs in escobar is home peralta's
home pavement smith with a two-run
double and it's a one-run ball game four
straight hits open up to seven no balls
two strikes marty's still the first now
two down on the eighth oh two of the
count
haven hits it deep to left center haven
smith
hits off the wall here comes cattell
pavon smith
has tied the ball game
a couple of blasted doubles for payment
smith tonight one to the gap in right
center this one to the gap in left
center
fastball up and out over the plate
narrowly missed hitting it out of the
ballpark
cargo's got a real good bounce off that
wall out there but the relay not in time
to get martay at home back to back rbi
doubles he's knocked in three we are
tied at four yachty or molina will bet
and the cardinals need something to
happen here
molina pulls it bare down into the left
field corner
goldsmith will score yadi on his way to
second base and he comes through here in
the 10th with one out and the cardinals
back on top five four
a three hit night for yada yada molina i
like this right there he just goes out
to get what he thinks is probably going
to be something out over the plate he
gets a sinker that stays
down the middle but stays up just enough
football gets elevated that might be a
homer that's the kind of swing he was
taking right there so molina has an rbi
double cardinals trying to win it in 10.
the one-two pitch round ball
sosa there and
he makes the play
the cardinals win it five to four in a
wild one game one in arizona ponce de
leon saves the game
terrific work by the cardinal
right-hander
in the bottom of the 10th inning and the
cardinals win this one 5-4